this what everybody came for right here snap snap
take your pictures on that one base off on Fifth
Avenue Crosby and McKinnon we're underway
for the pens and the ABS thanks for being
with us and with 8 seconds left on the power
play he finds Ricard Rael snaps that into the
Colorado end Smith picks it up over to Rael to
the net holding it hand on the shot bounces to
Smith shoots and scores just as mckin comes
out of the box Riley Smith goes upstairs and
a pen strike [Music] first it took uh the
Penguins pretty much the entire power play
just to gain entry and get get setting up and
they never able to really do that cleanly but
uh the puck kind of gets a friendly bounce
and gets on the tapable of Riley Smith right
here and he goes upstairs in a hurry to give
the Penguins a lead 100 plus points 50 goals
last season but he turns the puck over here
walking the other way over the line passing
leftward Zorna stop the post or did it go it
was close W heard the horn lead he can wire
it ni ranin back in hands it off to Gerard
drops it for ranin lost it duped here come
the pens at two on one it's Marin and
Smith Marin with it across for Smith
scores that's two for Riley Smith and the
penss are off and running here in this first
period Hil ma after it for bow and BM his pass
knocked down by a Chari in front a shot from
Eller is stopped by gorev and that is encouraging
right there from the bottom six in the penguin
there too after we take another look at this
this is good four checkin pressure in by aari
and get it out front and get a shot real quick
quick by lar Zeller just just stay the course
Let The Game come to you that was the best part
about that period they didn't force anything they
let the period come to them second period underway
Penguins back in their own and it's Graves living
on the edge with that kind of a goals against
total in the last two gorv though unbeaten this
year as are the ABS six and0 here's OK Conor in
centering in front jari a spectacular stop on
Frederick Olson wow jars is dialed [Applause] in
Conor wires one wide here's Taz from a CAU flips
it and that deflects through everyone wide of
the goal pushing left to right big blocker save
just he makes it look easy when jars is at his
best he's not overly animated he's Marcus Pon
with it there ahead for Smith two goals in the
first period case you're wondering as one career
hattrick came with the Vegas golden knights here's
Malin with it risting in and getting a piece of
that gorev for anony dropping it for Manson Wier
Pat save jari pens will try to go the other way
in a hurry here they go two onone Raquel and
Carlson Rael to Carlson shot it [Music] wide
that's a tough play to squeeze through almost
steart Carlson not able to get much on it oh
whips it to the net Sor a chance and that and
go you're going to see this chance by zahna
wow nice play little flippers little
pinball machine right there by
jorev wow man it's a tough spot I me Peng was
in their alternate Jes tonight depending on the
generation you may remember it from the90s or
you may remember it from Snoop Dog either way
they make it look good here's here's o Conor
back in stopping centering and he couldn't
hook up with it's loen put in L 's first goal in
Pittsburgh black and gold and the penguins are
rolling turnovers here and it's going to start
with another Colorado turnover and then just
get going and right there stick on Puck and
that's where zah Hornet when we said he does
things differently you don't teach that size
you don't teach that reach get that on stick
on puck right away and you're going to reap the
benefits of it it's a big time goal ma stripped
to the puck by OK con he did it again and he
just missed but the shot was turned aside by
Borgia they making it happen good stick sticking
with it that's kale Mari just stole that puff
from great chance Colton Manson back down low
the flex at top the crease big bounce better
save Tristan jari right there and ready and
this one's just the Jam play he's not leaky
on the short side he's covering all those areas
staying strong holding his ice Russ gold kind of
throw in Pon on top of Jar I wouldn't be
he remains with L Tang stick between the
pipes as marar comes in a cross ice feed Joe
Hansen down low for k the car in front drist
J take another look Mar is going to move this I
mean this is right in the slot drwan takes that
all the details and this PK has been providing
them let's see if they can get down for these
next 25 seconds Big faceof Win there to start
the frame from no aari and Chris L Tang will
send it down to Colorado ice third period this
season has belonged to the Avalanche out scoring
opponents 9-2 as McKinnon wires it back into
the Pittsburgh Zone Ma at the point 7 seconds
on the power play Tav shot blocked by the glove
of aari he felt it he's staying in The Fray Tes
the car Penguins kill off the Malin double Miner
and he's out of the box Ma's got the puck down
low for zahna protecting the puck well and now up
to L Tang ell throw Conor to the net and a save
made by gorv other the way comes McKinnon over
the line snapshot jar stops it and it's taken
away by Graves Pence two on two back the other
way here's the oconor take if they're going to
give you the ice if you have that room take it
drive that net hard as he does ggia makes his
Here Comes Colton back in for the ABS plenty of
time on this man Advantage as he wraps around the
net still 18 seconds on the Atari Miner byra for
Taves back to byon one timer missed the net yeah
changeed Direction dwan's got it anyway St drewan
cross ice byro jari are you kidding me ridiculous
stop guys this is jars getting across he's had
that numerous times in this game Heavy hit there
from Manson who can bring it as it comes down
to the Avalanche Zone Ranson in for McKinnon
you wonder how much we'll be heing those names
the final 10 minutes it's turnover though Crosby
rips it [Applause] [Music] scores Sydney Crosby
sizzles one through gorev and the pegs blowing
It Wide Open it's for SI push across has been
hot but look at Jake gensel at the other end
you saved one for us jars well I'm going to get a
turnover here and put it on our best player stick
it's Sydney Crosby and just wires it boom and you
know that feels good the Battle of Nova Scotia
owned Alexander gorv that's his team leading
sixth goal head to-head against the avalanch net
minder a chance in front here bounc it around
and steered wide hang on some dicey moments
after taking a 4 nothing lead maybe fitting
that this line is on the ice for the end of
this game as the longest regular season Road
winning streak in NHL history is history